[Music]
war than universal language that no
renegades old - Marcia never occurred to
me that one might come from above
space invasion
big car chase
truth be told I was ready to hang it up
to let miss you today so you're not for
her on here it's hard to explain
I keep having these memories
I see flashes
[Music]
I think I had a life here
[Music]
but I can't tell if it's real
we have no idea what threats are out
there
we can't do this alone
we need you
I'm not what you think I am
how's it going everybody it is finally
here just saw the Captain Marvel trailer
and I must say I was actually very
impressed very excited for this movie to
come out I think it's going to be
amazing real quick just a reminder about
the giveaway I'm doing I'm giving away a
copy of Avengers infinity war on blu-ray
a special edition poster and some
special infinity war memorabilia all you
have to do to enter is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero
[Music]
okay so there's some stuff to break down
so let's get right into it it starts off
with her falling from space and funny
enough she lands in a blockbuster
because we know this is taking place in
the 90s and what better way to show that
than to show a blockbuster
so she falls into the blockbuster and
Nick Fury starts narrating then we see
her walk into the world right this is
kind of foreign to her she's walking
around and everything is super confusing
because this is not her planet and then
you can hear Nick Fury call her a
soldier and it's true she is with Star
Force and she's wearing her green Star
Force uniform and Star Force is
basically described as the Navy SEALs of
the Kree so it seems like Nick Fury
finds her perhaps he saw her when she
fell and then kind of followed her
around because he says that he never
thought one of these soldiers would come
from above so he definitely knows that
she's an alien we go on to see this
scene where he knocks on the glass of
what looks like a phone booth and this
is clearly where they meet for the first
time again it seems like he's been
following her around probably saw her
fall out of the sky and judging by some
of these other clips it clearly seems
like he has ran into aliens before and
then we see for the very first time
live-action
Captain Marvel shooting energy out of
her hands and it looks amazing it really
does it's done very well I think she
might be hunting scroll here I think
that might be what brings her to earth
even though she crashed lands I think
that maybe perhaps she was supposed to
come to earth in the first place or
perhaps she's just trying to help Nick
Fury out and realizes that there are
scroll on here and she needs to take
care of him
so then Nick Fury says so you're not
from around here and Carol Danvers says
it's hard to explain and from this point
on Carol Danvers is the one narrating
the trailer so the next scene that we
have is actually of the Kree homeworld
which is very interesting we have never
seen it before so this is really awesome
to see then we go on to a series of
flashback scenes so we know that Captain
Marvel isn't going to be an origin story
movie at least not in the typical way
she goes on to say that she keeps having
these memories and flashbacks
she thinks she had a life on earth but
she can't tell if they're real so as
she's saying this we're seeing all these
flashes of when she was an Air Force
pilot when she was going through Air
Force training when she was a kid so
although this is not going to be a
typical origin movie we are going to see
a little bit of a glimpse of who she was
before she became Captain Marvel you see
her fall down in her Air Force uniform
and it cuts to her hand and you can see
this blue energy circling around it and
this is probably right where she gets
her powers
she gets her powers from a Kree
explosion in the comics so it seems like
they're kind of sticking along the same
storyline there from her getting her
powers from an explosion then we have
this very interesting scene where she's
upside down in this device and sort of
lasers going into her head it clearly
seems like the Kree are erasing her
memory of when she was a human on earth
so for whatever reason that seems to be
what's going on here and this is why she
feels like she used to have a life on
earth but all she has is these
flashbacks that kind of creep in every
now and then and she doesn't know if
they're real or not because they're
clearly erasing her memory we then see
her on the Kree homeworld again with
Star Force and then we see Jude Law who
is still not officially confirmed to
play Marvel but if they kind of take at
the comic book route he should be
playing Marvel marvelous who helps Carol
Danvers sort of harness her powers and
eventually become Captain Marvel more
flashbacks of her when she was a kid
when she was an Air Force pilot and then
Scrolls so introducing the scrolls
clearly going to be at least one of the
main villains in this movie you see them
come up on the beach and then you see
Carol Danvers just punched us old lady
in the face and that's clearly because
she's a scroll if you're not familiar
with who the scroll are they can
shape-shift so it's not just some poor
old lady that she punches it's clearly a
scroll of disguise and then we see young
Agent Coulson we've seen young Nick Fury
now with two eyes but we never saw young
Coulson so this is pretty cool him and
fury have worked together for such a
long time clearly this takes place in
the 90s and they have such a fun dynamic
between the two of them I'm really
excited to see this on screen we also
see a very brief clip of Ronan the
accuser at this point in time and
Captain Marvel he is not
the crazy Cree fanatic that we know from
guardians of the galaxy but it is most
likely that we're going to see him
become that in this movie so then we see
theory and we see the pager that we saw
at the end of Avengers infinity war so
we'll learn more about that in this
movie then we have this really awesome
scene of Star Force and space so it
looks like they're jumping from their
ship going somewhere else but what's
awesome here is Captain Marvel is
wearing her helmet I was wondering if we
were going to get this in the movie I am
so excited that we do and then we see
this explosion and if you look she is
still in her Air Force uniform so this
seems like it's clearly when she gets
her powers it shows her hand and you can
clearly see the energy going into her
body
so although not a typical origin story
we are going to see how she got her
powers and a little bit of who she was
before she became Captain Marvel another
scene with her wearing her helmet again
I love it seems like she's holding onto
this bar for some reason maybe she's in
space I'm not sure but I love the fact
that we're having scenes where she's
wearing her helmet and then we have this
final scene where she says I'm not what
you think I am
and then we see for the very first time
Captain Marvel full power energy
circling all around her this is what
makes Captain Marvel so strong this is
why they're saying Captain Marvel is
going to be the strongest character in
the MCU because of her powers so she has
the ability to control and project
energy but she can also absorb energy
and when she does absorb energy and she
projects that energy out as an attack it
has the power of a nuclear bomb so
that's what we see right here her
harnessing all of this energy looks like
she's about to explode on somebody this
trailer was amazing it was fantastic I
really loved it I'm really excited and
looking forward to seeing Captain Marvel
when it comes out now not that I wasn't
before but this is awesome this really
did blow me away so what did you all
think I want to know all your thoughts
and opinions let me know in the comments
below another reminder about the
giveaway I'm doing I'm giving a
a copy of Avengers infinity war a
special edition poster and some special
memorabilia as well I'll put the link
for the memorabilia in the description
below be sure to check it out
all you have to do to enter is subscribe
to my channel like this video and
comment below with your thoughts and
your favorite superhero thank you all so
much for watching woof woof
[Music]
you